Vous voyez bien qu’Haristote est minuscule.
Et du coup,
TOUT ce qui sort de son corps est minuscule.
Je ne sais pas si vous me voyez venir...
S’il fait nuit lorsque je le sors,
eh bien j’ai du mal à voir ses…
merdes
— j’ai besoin de la lampe torche de mon
iPhone
pour les voir distinctement
avant de les ramasser.
Alors je sais bien,
c’est bizarre comme accroche.
Quel est donc le rapport
avec la rédaction
d’un argument de dissertation ?
Je vous rassure :
vous regardez bien la bonne vidéo.
Regardez-la jusqu’au bout,
et vous saurez rédiger un argument de dissertation
à la PER-FEC-TION.
Avant de vous expliquer
le sens de mon accroche bizarre,
je vous invite à vous inscrire
à mon cours gratuit de méthodologie
qui vous explique TOUT
de A à Z,
avec des schémas et des exemples.
Regardez ce que les gens en pensent :
Vous pouvez vous aussi le recevoir
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
soit en utilisant celui qui est
dans la description de cette vidéo.
Inscrivez-vous,
et vous m’en direz des nouvelles.
Alors,
quel est le sens de mon accroche ?
Ce que je veux vous dire,
c’est que sans la lumière,
je ne serais pas capable d’identifier
l’objet « matériel » dans l’espace
afin de pouvoir le saisir.
Vous voyez la lampe torche de mon iPhone ?
Eh bien,
un argument c’est ça,
une lampe torche
— mais dans le monde des idées.
Le mot « argument » vient du grec argos,
qui signifie « blanc, clair ».
Ça veut dire qu’un argument sert à apporter
de la CLARTÉ.
Donner un argument,
c’est appuyer sur le bouton d’une lampe
torche :
l’interlocuteur doit y voir plus clair dans
votre propos,
afin de mieux saisir vos idées,
qui sont des objets
INTELLECTUELS.
Donc un argument FAVORISE
la compréhension de votre discours.
En dissertation,
les arguments sont les phrases qui permettent
au correcteur
de comprendre votre réponse à la problématique.
Ce sont les premières phrases
des paragraphes du développement,
celles qui présentent les idées directrices
de votre raisonnement.
Or,
ces phrases sont CRUCIALES :
si elles sont ratées,
le correcteur n’y verra rien
dans votre raisonnement
— et vous,
vous ramasserez une sale note.
Alors,
comment rédiger un argument de dissertation
EFFICACE ?
Comment éclairer vos idées
avec une lumière
PUISSANTE ?
Dans le monde des idées,
vous ne pouvez pas utiliser un iPhone !
Je vous donne ma formule en 6 points.
Regardez bien cette vidéo jusqu’au bout,
et vous passerez à un niveau supérieur en
dissertation
— vous allez gagner facilement des points
dès votre prochain devoir.
Allez,
PREMIER point pour rédiger
un argument de dissertation
à la perfection.
Je vous l’ai dit,
la première phrase du paragraphe,
qui présente l’argument,
cette phrase est la plus importante
— donc il est capital
que le correcteur puisse la comprendre
FACILEMENT.
Comment faire ?
Eh bien,
il faut déjà qu’elle soit courte.
En effet,
les études expérimentales sur la lecture
montrent
que les phrases les plus courtes
sont statistiquement les mieux comprises
et les mieux mémorisées.
En présentant votre argument avec une phrase
courte,
vous permettrez donc au correcteur
de COMPRENDRE
l’idée directrice du paragraphe,
mais aussi de la retenir
pour lire la suite de la dissertation.
Maintenant,
comment,
en pratique,
rédiger une phrase courte ?
Le premier critère,
c’est bien sûr le nombre de mots :
essayez d’en écrire moins de DOUZE
— et tant que vous êtes en dessous de quinze,
ça va.
Le second critère,
c’est le nombre de verbes conjugués :
limitez-vous à UN SEUL verbe conjugué
— vous allez rédiger
ce qu’on appelle une phrase « simple ».
Alors maintenant,
je vous donne des exemples.
Lisez cet argument :
« Le travail est déshumanisant
lorsqu'il transforme l’individu en esclave
ou lorsqu’il prive le travailleur de toutes
les possibilités
que sa vie d’homme lui offre.
»
La phrase n’est PAS efficace
parce qu’elle est trop longue
— elle comporte vingt-quatre mots —
et parce qu’il y a QUATRE verbes conjugués.
Lisez maintenant cet argument :
« Le travail s’avère déshumanisant pour
l’individu.
»
La phrase est efficace
parce qu’elle est courte
— elle comporte SIX mots —
et parce qu’il y a UN SEUL verbe conjugué.
Donc retenez bien :
un argument de dissertation efficace,
c’est une phrase COURTE,
avec UN SEUL verbe conjugué.
Allez,
on passe au deuxième point.
Que la phrase soit courte,
ça ne suffit pas à garantir qu’on la comprenne
facilement.
Lisez par exemple celle-ci :
« L’idiosyncrasie se substitue d’elle-même
à l’ontologie.
»
Elle ne fait que six mots ;
elle ne comporte qu’UN SEUL verbe conjugué
;
et pourtant,
je ne sais pas vous,
mais moi je ne l’ai pas comprise !
En plus d’être courte,
la phrase qui présente l’argument de dissertation
doit donc être CLAIRE.
« Claire »,
ça veut dire qu’on VOIT
IMMÉDIATEMENT
l’idée de l’argument
— comme si elle était éclairée par un
spot.
En tant que lecteur,
on n’a AUCUN effort à faire.
On saisit l’idée
INSTANTANÉMENT.
Mais comment écrire une phrase CLAIRE
en pratique ?
Vous devez faire attention à deux choses
:
la première,
c’est d’exprimer UNE SEULE idée
— pas deux,
pas trois,
UNE SEULE idée bien identifiable ;
la seconde chose,
c’est d’éviter autant que possible le
jargon,
les termes techniques,
et donc de préférer des mots
de la langue ordinaire.
Je reprends mon exemple.
« Le travail s’avère déshumanisant pour
l’individu.
»
Cette phrase exprime clairement UNE SEULE
idée,
l’effet déshumanisant du travail.
Les mots « travail »,
« s’avérer »,
et « individu »
ne posent aucun problème.
Après,
le terme « déshumanisant » est un peu technique,
mais on comprend quand même facilement l’idée
:
c’est perdre
ce qui fait de nous un être humain.
Je pourrais éventuellement clarifier l’argument
en écrivant
« Le travail dépouille l’individu de sa
dignité humaine. »
— mais bon,
je trouve que la première version
est déjà assez claire.
Donc retenez bien :
un argument de dissertation efficace,
c’est une phrase TRÈS CLAIRE,
dont on comprend l’idée
INSTANTANÉMENT.
Allez,
on passe au troisième point.
Une des erreurs
que commettent beaucoup d’élèves en dissertation,
c’est qu’ils se contredisent.
On leur a parlé du plan thèse antithèse
synthèse,
donc ils croient qu’ils peuvent affirmer
une chose,
puis son contraire.
Le premier souci avec cette manière de faire,
c’est L’INCOHÉRENCE.
Vous ne pouvez pas dire
« Le tee-shirt de Romain est noir. »,
puis « Le tee-shirt de Romain est bleu. »,
parce qu’un tee-shirt ne peut pas avoir
deux couleurs en même temps
— vous êtes en train de vous contredire.
Le second souci avec cette manière de faire,
c’est que vous affirmez avec CERTITUDE
une chose FAUSSE.
Vous dites que vous êtes sûr
que mon tee-shirt est bleu,
alors qu’il est noir.
Comment pouvez-vous éviter À LA FOIS
de vous contredire
et de défendre des idées fausses ?
En vous exprimant AVEC NUANCE.
N’écrivez pas
« Le tee-shirt de Romain est bleu. »,
mais « Le tee-shirt de Romain SEMBLE bleu.
».
Cela a deux avantages.
Cela vous permettra tout d’abord
de dire plus tard que,
sous un autre angle,
avec une autre lumière,
eh bien là le tee-shirt semble noir.
Et le second avantage,
c’est que vous vous donnez
le droit à l’erreur.
Vous précisez bien,
en employant le verbe « sembler »,
qu’il s’agit de l’APPARENCE du tee-shirt.
Le tee-shirt vous PARAÎT bleu,
mais il peut très bien être noir
— et s’il est noir,
vous n’aurez pas commis une erreur,
vous n’aurez pas DÉFENDU
une idée FAUSSE.
Je reprends mon exemple.
« Le travail s’avère déshumanisant pour
l’individu.
»
Là,
ma phrase manque de modération,
parce que le travail n’est pas TOUJOURS
déshumanisant.
Est-ce que le travail de Neymar
est déshumanisant ?
Je ne crois pas, non !
Est-ce qu’être médecin,
c’est déshumanisant ?
Bien sûr que non.
En réalité,
c’est UN CERTAIN TYPE de travail
qui est déshumanisant
— par exemple,
celui des enfants qui étaient ouvriers dans
les usines
pendant la Révolution industrielle.
Je dois donc CORRIGER
la formulation de l’argument.
Il vaut mieux écrire :
« Le travail PEUT s’avérer déshumanisant
pour l’individu.
»
Grâce au verbe « pouvoir »,
je montre que l’idée a valeur d’HYPOTHÈSE,
que ce n’est pas une vérité absolue.
Cet argument témoigne de ma MATURITÉ intellectuelle
:
je ne prétends pas détenir la vérité
AVANT MÊME d’avoir réfléchi
au problème intellectuel de la dissertation,
mais j’AVANCE
hypothèse par hypothèse,
comme un scientifique.
Et puis cet argument me laisse la liberté
d’examiner l’idée opposée,
le caractère ÉPANOUISSANT du travail,
plus tard dans un autre paragraphe
de la même dissertation.
Donc retenez bien :
un argument de dissertation efficace
est empreint de NUANCE.
Point numéro quatre !
Si vous avez déjà regardé certaines de
mes vidéos,
ou lu certains de mes articles sur la dissertation,
alors vous connaissez probablement déjà
ce point.
Je répète souvent que le but de la dissertation,
ce n’est pas de réciter son cours.
Vous n’êtes plus au collège !
La dissertation est un exercice de RÉFLEXION
et d’EXPRESSION ÉCRITE
— donc les connaissances ne sont PAS la
priorité.
C’est pour cette raison qu’un argument
de dissertation
ne doit comporter AUCUNE référence
ou connaissance.
Un argument,
c’est un ÉLÉMENT DE RÉPONSE
à la problématique,
c’est une hypothèse
issue de votre PROPRE réflexion
sur le sujet de la dissertation
— donc inutile de mentionner un auteur,
un ouvrage,
et plus généralement
de mobiliser une quelconque référence.
Je reprends mon exemple.
« Le travail peut s’avérer déshumanisant
pour l’individu.
»
Pas de référence,
donc la phrase respecte le quatrième point
en l’état.
Il ne fallait pas écrire par exemple :
« Marx affirme que le travail
peut s’avérer déshumanisant.
».
Donc retenez bien :
pas de référence ou de connaissance
dans un argument de dissertation !
On passe au cinquième point.
Si je vous demande l’heure,
vous n’allez pas me répondre
« Il pleut. »
— ou alors il faut aller consulter.
Non,
parce que quand on vous pose une question,
vous répondez
de manière PERTINENTE.
Eh bien c’est pareil en dissertation :
on vous pose une question,
la problématique,
donc vous devez y répondre précisément
— vous ne devez pas répondre à côté.
Or,
un argument,
c’est un élément de réponse à la problématique.
Il doit donc ABSOLUMENT
être PERTINENT.
Le mot « pertinence » vient du verbe latin
pertinere,
qui signifie « atteindre ».
Votre argument doit donc ATTEINDRE sa cible,
c’est-à-dire répondre
À LA QUESTION POSÉE.
En pratique,
vous devez surtout
DONNER L’IMPRESSION de la pertinence,
parce que le correcteur lit la copie
très rapidement.
Comment DONNER L’IMPRESSION
que vous touchez juste ?
En reprenant le mot-clé du sujet
(ou une alternative)
et en renvoyant à la formulation du sujet.
L’objectif,
c’est que le correcteur fasse instantanément
la connexion
entre votre argument
et l’énoncé.
Je reprends mon exemple.
Le sujet est
« Travailler, est-ce vivre mieux ? »
Et mon argument est
« Le travail peut s’avérer déshumanisant
pour l’individu.
»
Le mot « déshumanisant »
renverse le sens du mot-clé du sujet,
qui est l’adverbe « mieux »
— si c’est déshumanisant,
ce n’est pas mieux,
c’est pire.
Et puis le nom commun « travail »,
c’est la notion-clé du sujet.
En conclusion,
il est impossible de croire
que mon argument est hors-sujet
— bien au contraire,
tel qu’il est rédigé,
il touche en plein dans le mille.
Retenez donc bien :
un argument de dissertation efficace
doit créer une FORTE impression de pertinence
en reprenant le mot-clé du sujet
et en renvoyant plus globalement
à la formulation du sujet.
Allez,
sixième et dernier point !
Votre argument de dissertation n’est pas
seul au monde.
Il s’intègre dans une structure :
Il a une place
et un rôle.
Ça,
on doit normalement le comprendre FACILEMENT
en lisant votre dissertation
— mais si on peut
ne pas avoir
à faire l’EFFORT de le comprendre,
c’est encore mieux.
Qu’est-ce que je veux dire ?
Eh bien,
je veux dire
que vous devez accompagner le lecteur par
la main
— c’est une image, hein —
donc vous devez accompagner le lecteur par
la main
afin qu’il ne se perde pas
dans les étapes de votre raisonnement.
Ça,
c’est L’IDÉE du sixième point
— vous allez voir que c’est très simple
en pratique.
EN PRATIQUE,
vous pouvez vous contenter d’indiquer
dans la formulation de l’argument
le lien qui existe entre l’idée de cet
argument
et celle du précédent.
Est-ce que l’idée de cet argument
est une CONSÉQUENCE
de celle du précédent ?
Est-ce que c’est la CAUSE ?
Est-ce qu’elle la PROLONGE ?
Bref,
ne laissez pas le correcteur chercher le lien.
Dites-le-lui CLAIREMENT
avec un mot de liaison.
Je reprends mon exemple.
« Le travail peut s’avérer déshumanisant
pour l’individu.
»
Là,
je donne aucune indication.
Si l’idée de l’argument renchérit par
rapport à la précédente,
je pourrais écrire :
« Le travail peut MÊME
s’avérer déshumanisant pour l’individu.
»
Si l’idée une conséquence de la précédente,
je pourrais écrire :
« Le travail peut AINSI
s’avérer déshumanisant pour l’individu.
»
Si les deux idées s’opposent :
« Le travail peut CEPENDANT
s’avérer déshumanisant pour l’individu.
»
Et caetera.
Retenez donc bien :
un argument de dissertation efficace
indique CLAIREMENT sa place
dans la structure intellectuelle
— et en pratique,
il suffit de connecter l’idée de l’argument
à celle de l’argument précédent
avec un mot de liaison.
Ça y est :
vous connaissez ma formule
pour rédiger un argument de dissertation
À LA PERFECTION.
Je vous rappelle les six points :
rédigez une phrase courte ;
très claire ;
nuancée ;
sans aucune référence ou connaissance ;
reprenez le mot-clé du sujet
et renvoyez à la formulation du sujet ;
et enfin,
introduisez un mot de liaison
pour connecter l’argument au précédent.
Voilà voilà,
j’espère que cette vidéo vous a plu,
et qu’elle vous sera utile.
Si vous avez des questions,
n’hésitez pas à laisser un commentaire.
Je vous rappelle que vous pouvez
vous inscrire pour recevoir
mon cours gratuit de méthodologie de la dissertation
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
soit en utilisant celui
qui est dans la description de cette vidéo.
Je suis Romain,
je suis toujours avec mon fidèle Haristote,
et vous étiez sur 1000 idées de culture
générale.
Rappelez-vous que n’avez pas besoin de vous
prendre la tête
pour rédiger un SUPER argument de dissertation.